[Musica]
sì c'è nessuno lo tieni marino
andiamo
[Musica]
7 1.500 lire prima edizione 1995
vuoi giocare con me anita fermato s sì
c'è nessuno
[Musica]
cosa si fa
questo strano pacco
smack
era il campanello hanno suonato e hanno
portato un pacco
questo è una busta con un libro nel
mittente c'è scritto caro murray o donna
lombo l'onu carraro sembrati una lingua
straniera
capisco questa politica perché qualcuno
dovrebbe andarci una bambola secondo te
cosa significa
ma dai sarà uno scherzo fammi vedere
questa bambola mi sembra sembra un
burattino una bambola per due trilogo ma
perché qualcuno dovrebbe inviarci un
burattino non ha senso questa cosa ma
dai è super divertente guarda la vanità
chi è fan di via mercato allora tutti a
pezzi io penso che a vita una figura è
stata fissata dai basta da me l'ha o non
voglia di scherzare come oggi
[Risate]
però anche tu a farla parlare è andata
stata attaccata come funziona dai è
facile ti basta mettere la mano dietro e
decidi dove muovere la faccia e la bocca
è molto semplice può far dire quello che
vuoi
ho tanta fame ad esempio fatemi mangiare
o problemi di mangiare tutto guardo
berlino abbiamo un nuovo amico ti piace
e il merlino dio sono troppi vuoi venire
a conoscermi sono una bambola fi
il trillo proprio come si dice una
bambola per 21 fa piacere di conoscerti
vuoi fare la mia conoscenza di piazza
scommetto che diventeremo un migliore
amici gli amici cane è il burattino
saremo migliori amici proprio ti piace e
berlino allontanati da mente spiaggia
stai dicendo berlino poverino dai ma io
non ho detto niente ti giuro è stato sua
ma che dici dai secondo te io ci casco
su queste cose sono io che ti faccio
questi scherzi ora secondo te aiuti
dovrebbe mai visto che la mia bocca non
si muoveva
ma se lo sta muovendo fino adesso guarda
che è una bambola per ben tre i loro
il che significa che c'è una persona che
con la sua stessa voce camuffandola
parla come se fosse un altra voce ma in
realtà la bambola non parla da sola
ebbene non credermi dai secondo me tutta
questa situazione che ti ho dato un po
alla testa prima il pacco poi il libro
poi l'indirizzo strano da n o mangiare
così almeno ti sentirai meglio dopo si
forse è meglio dai andiamo
appoggio
[Musica]
vestito si berlino berlino che ci arrivo
per che stavi appaiando berlino sei
stato tu berlino
ti sei nascosto che cosa hai fatto qua
sei stato tu hai fatto questo scherzo
merlino
[Musica]
ma
che cosa è successo guarda guerra che ho
trovato cosa lo so è assurdo
ovviamente pensavo fosse stato berlino
ma berlino non può fare una cosa del
genere non ha le mani alle zampe
quindi ho guardato bene la bambola si
faccia vedere che cosa vedi è stata la
bambola vedi il vento smettila che
scherzi mi stai facendo che non mi credi
che può essere stato non può essere
stato merlino dai mai fatto proprio
bello lo scherzo questa volta ti sei
proprio impegnata non ne hai smesso ma
che stai dicendo per favore basta
prendermi credermi
adesso basta prendo io questa bambola
non si può aver paura di una bambola il
vero merlino che non si può avere paura
di una bambola che la pensi tu
[Musica]
siamo qua sopra insieme agli altri
pupazzi e lo facciamo dormire così sta
bello tranquillo che ne pensi ha mosso
gli occhi dai basta questa storia ma un
po stancato adesso dai andiamo via dalla
camera
[Musica]
andiamo
no
[Musica]